يعني انا التحقت بالحزب بالتجمع الدستوري
الديمقراطي في ربيعه 88 يعني بعد بضع شهور
بعد بعد
تولي بن علي السلطه وبعد تغيير الاسم وفتح
الابواب
من قار امين
مساعد للامين العام
لمده سنه ونصف او شيء منها القبيل حتى
التحقت برئاسه الجمهوريه سنه 92 ما كان
همم نوع من الشعور عندك بانه هذه مجرد انا
وين براقه شعارات فقط يعني دستوري
وديموقراطي في بلد متهم بانتخابات مزوره
بجد انتخابات مزوره كل البلدان اصبح حتى
التهامي بعدها بالانتخابات
والانتخابات كانت تعبر
عن شيء الله اعلم ان كان هنالك التزوير 81
مثلا
الاغذيه النتائج بعض الاطراف في السلطه
وفي الحزب ان ذلك
فاوقف المسار بشكل كاد يكون يعني ولكن
فيما بعد
في بدايه
الاقبال على الانتخابات كان جديا حتى
انتخابات 89 التي شاركت فيها عنه بقائمات
مستقله هيك
وان النتيجه التي خرجت
للاعلام كانت 13.8% في المياه
وهذا لم يكن يعني السلطه لم يكن يعني
مقاطع حقيقيه
2011 في ال في الانتخابات الاولى التي تمت
همم
معناها لا لا لم يصل ال 50% ولا فائق
ال40% 28 ولا 28 فما تقلص شيئا فشيئا وهذا
تخلص لي لانه فشلوا في الحكم همم بس شو
اللي اخذك من المعارضه ايام برجيبه الى
اولا الى الحكم لم اذهب من المعارضه
مباشره الحكم لانه هنالك فتره من 85 من
اكتوبر 85 حتى ل 88
انشغلتم فيها فقط بالعمل الجامعي
والاكاديمي بتاعي
خرجت من عام 95
اكاديميا ورئيسا للجمعيه التونسيه لعلم
الاجتماع عضو في الجمعيه العربيه الى اخره
العديد من الاصدقاء
حركه الديمقراطيين الاشتراكيه مثل
المرحوم
القانون
الدستوري
وغيرهم يعني
العديد من الوجوه الموجوده في البلاد التي
لها تاريخ نقابه اجتماعي سياسي اجتماعي او
يسارنا او مؤمن الديمقراطيه الاشتراكين
كلهم يستحقوا بالحزب المشروع يعني
لم اتعرف عليه الى السنه 92